c'est une nouvelle très attendue pour
cette rentrée scolaire à montargis aller
à l'école en bus c'est dorénavant
gratuit c'est la fin de l'abonnement
payant pour près de 3000 jeunes lycéens
et collégiens
ce dossier était sur le feu depuis un an
et demi date où la région a décidé
d'instaurer la gratuité pour le réseau
rémy l'agglomération montargoise a donc
fait le choix de s'aligner
les gens étaient complètement perdus il
allait jusqu'à l'agglo aux limites de la
ghost et gratuit dès qu'ils rentraient
dans la ghost est payant donc là
maintenant on est en aller on a les
mêmes on dirige les mêmes conditions que
la bluecar région a mis en place pour
ses transports à elle donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile c'est beaucoup plus
compréhensible pour les parents et pour
les élèves mais justement qu'en est il
aujourd'hui des élèves des parents pour
certains c'est un réel coup de pouce
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que avant
devaient garder un budget pour la carte
de mu alors comme un nom
oui c'est quoi c'est plutôt cool et puis
pour d'autres l'arrivée de cette
nouvelle formule exclusivement dédié un
aller-retour scolaire non valable au
week-end ni pendant les vacances avec
des horaires très précis oblige certains
parents à prendre un autre abonnement et
cette fois-ci payant via quinqua seul
horaire que le matin donc ça nous
intéressait pas parce que si ma fille
ait commencé plus tard l'école ben
c'était pas possible donc alors et lui
fait deux heures d'études moi j'ai payé
pour deux enfants 330 euros 165 euros
par enfant donc pour vous c'était pas
gratuit c'est pas gratuite non c'est pas
gratuit et chaque année moi j'ai déjà
une fille au collège
cette année le pas
au lycée donc ça fait quatre ans que je
pèse 165 euros chaque année dans le
loiret seule la métropole d'orléans n'a
toujours pas instaurer la gratuité des
abonnements pour les trajets des
écoliers